resultados avanza superior al 50% pero
en la mayoría de las respuestas la
tendencia es hacia el no lo que cual
quiere decir que la consulta popular por
parte del gobierno sería perdida dado
que las principales propuestas emitidas
por parte del ejecutivo nacional han
obtenido un resultado negativo entre las
principales
resultados de lo escrutados hasta el
momento los referentes a la extradición
que proponía la extradición de personas
e inmersas en crímenes transnacionales
avanza con el sesenta por ciento a favor
del no De igual forma encuentro la
autonomía y la fiscalía también avanza
ya con un resultado superior de 58% De
igual forma en cuanto a la
reestructuración de la asamblea nacional
la reducción de parlamentarios ya avanza
con un porcentaje de 56% Y así también
cuanto a la reducción de los la
afiliación de los partidos políticos ya
avanza con un cincuenta y siete por
ciento los resultados se han traducido
en un termómetro de valoración de la
gestión del presidente Guillermo lasso
qué ha sucedido Bueno hasta el momento
El Ejecutivo nacional ha mantenido el
silencio ha suspendido tanto las
vocerías que tenían planteada para la
noche de ayer De igual forma el Consejo
Nacional electoral no ha emitido ningún
pronunciamiento ni cuando se emitirá por
el momento avanza los resultados y esto
ha generado una inquietud y diversas
opiniones en las redes sociales en
cuanto cuál sería el el futuro de
Ecuador y qué significará esto para el
gobierno de Guillermo lasso